what we're going to do in this video is
talk about what is often referred to as
the bully pulpit of the united states
president and it's making reference to
the idea that the president has a
platform from which they can convince
people that they can convey their own
message there are explicit powers in the
united states constitution about what
the president can and cannot do but just
as being that singular executive at the
top of the executive branch people are
going to pay attention to what they say
and this term bully pulpit probably
isn't exactly what you imagine it to
mean it actually comes to us from
theodore roosevelt it's a picture of
theodore roosevelt giving a speech he
was president from 1901 to 1909. he was
actually the youngest person to hold the
office of president he took office when
president mckinley was assassinated and
this is a quote from 1909 from lyman
abbott who wrote for the outlook
half a dozen of us were with the
president theodore roosevelt in his
library he was sitting at his desk
reading to us his forthcoming message he
had just finished reading a paragraph of
a distinctly ethical character when he
suddenly stopped swung around in his
swivel chair and said i suppose my
critics will call that preaching but i
have got such a bully pulpit and
theodore roosevelt was famous for using
the term bully a lot and it doesn't mean
to pick on people in the theodore
roosevelt's context he used it as great
wonderful bully for you good for you so
when he said a bully pulpit he's saying
i have such a great platform from what
wish to speak he's not saying i have a
platform from which to pick on people
and this was before mass media became a
significant influence in politics at
this time recorded audio was just
starting to become a thing television
was not an influence in politics but you
could imagine once you have mass media
especially radio television and now
social media becoming a major factor
this bully pulpit has only gotten more
and more and more significant
one of the strongest examples of
presidents using their bully pulpit is
the state of the union address state
of the union the constitution does call
for the president to make reports to
congress on the state of the union but
early presidents like thomas jefferson
just sent a written report but
eventually over time the president
started giving live reports to the joint
houses of congress in the form of a
speech and then in 1947
you have truman's state of the union is
televised
truman
and so today the state of the union is
given every january this is a major
event all the major networks show it the
nation pays attention and so what
theodore roosevelt was talking about
becomes even more powerful for modern
presidents that have mass media at their
disposal and to get a good tangible
sense of this power that a president has
i'm going to show you a video from 1981.
this actually will not be a state of the
union address this is an address that
president reagan gives to the nation on
federal tax reduction just so you have
context on what the world was like or
what the united states was like in 1981
they had stagflation a stagnant economy
with a lot of inflation and high
interest rates i remember at the time my
mom had i think it was a 17 interest
rate on her mortgage which is incredibly
incredibly high and so what you're going
to see is president reagan making a
direct plea to the american people to
convince their representatives to
support his tax plan and think about
what president reagan was able to do
that thomas jefferson or even theodore
roosevelt could have only dreamed of
the best way to have a strong foreign
policy abroad
is to have a strong economy at home
now the day after tomorrow wednesday
the house of representatives will begin
debate on two tax bills
and once again they need to hear from
you
i know that doesn't give you much time
but a great deal is at stake
let me add those representatives
honestly and sincerely want to know your
feelings
they get plenty of input from the
special interest groups
they'd like to hear from their home
folks
now let me explain what the situation is
and what's at issue
with our budget cuts we presented a
complete program of reduction in tax
rates
again our purpose was to provide
incentive for the individual incentives
for business to encourage production and
hiring of the unemployed
and to free up money for investment
our bill calls for a five percent
reduction in the income tax rates by
october first
a ten percent reduction beginning july
first nineteen eighty two
and another ten percent cut a year later
a twenty five percent total reduction
over three years
but then to ensure the tax cut is
permanent
we call for indexing the tax rates in
which means adjusting them for inflation
as it is now if you get a cost of living
raised that's intended to keep you even
with inflation
you find that the increase in the number
of dollars you get may very likely move
you into a higher tax bracket
and you wind up poorer than you were
this is called bracket creep
bracket creep is insidious tax let me
give an example
if you earned ten thousand dollars a
year in 1972
by 1980
you had to earn nineteen thousand seven
hundred dollars just to stay even with
inflation
but that's before taxes
come april 15th you find your tax rates
have increased 30 percent
have you been wondering why you don't
seem as well off as you were a few years
back
it's because government makes a profit
on inflation